three reasons why we should stop using
nuclear energy
one. nuclear weapons proliferation
nuclear technology made a violent
entrance onto the world stage
just one year after the world's
first-ever nuclear test explosion in
two large cities were destroyed by just
two single bombs
after that, reactor technology slowly
evolved as a means of generating
electricity but it's always been
intimately connected with nuclear
weapons technology
it's nearly impossible to develop
nuclear weapons without access to reactor
technology
in fact the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty serves the purpose of spreading
nuclear reactor technology
without spreading nuclear weapons, with
limited success
in forty years five countries have
developed their own weapons with the
help of reactor technology
the fact of the matter is that it can be
very hard to distinguish
a covert nuclear weapons program from
the peaceful use of nuclear energy
in the nineteen seventies the big
nuclear powers were happily selling
peaceful technology to smaller countries
which then developed weapons of their
own
the road to deadly nuclear weapons is
always paved with peaceful reactors
2. nuclear waste and pollution spent
nuclear fuel is not only radioactive
but also contains extremely poisonous
chemical elements like plutonium
it loses its harmfulness only slowly over
several tens of thousands of years
and there is also a process called re
processing
which means the extraction of plutonium
from spent nuclear fuel
it can be used for two purposes: to build
nuclear weapons
or to use it as new fuel, but hardly
any of it is used as fuel
because we don't have the right kind of
reactors for that, a milligram
will kill you a few kilograms make an
atomic bomb and even an inconspicuous
country like Germany
literally has tons of the stuff just
lying around because re processing
sounded like a good idea decades ago
and
Where will all the waste go? after dumping it into
the ocean was forbidden
we've tried to bury it, but we can't find
a place where it will definitely stay
secure for tens of thousands of years
over 30 countries operate nearly 400
reactors
managing several hundred thousands of
tons of nuclear waste
and only one is currently serious about
opening
a permanent civilian waste storage: tiny
Finland
3. accidents and disasters
over sixty years of nuclear power usage
there have been seven major accidents in
reactors
or facilities dealing with nuclear waste
three of those were mostly contained
but four of them released significant amounts
of radioactivity into the
environment
in 1957, 1987 and 2011
large areas of land in Russia Ukraine
and Japan
Were rendered unfit for human habitation for
decades to come
the number of deaths is highly disputed
But probably lies in the thousands
these disasters happened with nuclear
reactors of very different types
in very different countries and several
decades apart
looking at the numbers we may as well
ask ourselves: are 10 percent of the
world's energy supply
worth a devastating disaster every 30
years?
would thirty percent be worth another
Fukushima or chernobyl somewhere on
earth
every 10 years? what area would have to
be contaminated
so we say no more? where is the line?
so should we use nuclear energy?
the risks may outweigh the benefits and
maybe we should stop looking into this
direction
and drop this technology for good if you
want to hear the other side of the
argument